cats have voted in an election
I explain you how it is possible
so it happened this weekend
in the first round of the Republican referendum
quickly this election
is to elect the new party president
of the right the Republicans
who will succeed christian jacob
who left his funds last July
you have to know that it is an election
exclusively reserved
to party members
so to the people who are members of the party
the problem is that two cats managed to vote
in the first round of this weekend
well in truth they are not really two cats
in fact two journalists from the Sunday newspaper
wanted to test the voting methods of the election
by registering their two cats
cali and zizou
have therefore visited the website of the republics
and we fill in the coordinates
by writing cali and zizou
they then paid forty euros
before receiving an email of thanks
and their membership number
and their official map
after this
they were able to quietly vote Saturday night online
without their identity being controlled
only once
on the Republican side
well nobody has reacted publicly for the moment
you suspect it
several opponents have already made fun of the party
on social networks
It does not change the vote
kali chose éric ciotti and zizou aurélien pradier
then you have to know
that it is not the first time
that the party is causing controversy
with its false votes
last February
in the Republican primary
which was therefore used to elect the candidate
who would represent the party in the crown
a dog named Douglas had managed to vote